MP Dame Angela Eagle who sits on the
treasury select committee is with us hi
good to see you uh you talked about the
bank's profiteering are they
profiteering or just profiting
I think um I think the profits are going
to be colossal if you look at what
happened last year nearly five billion
pounds extra profit made on the
difference between the uh interest rate
that borrowers have to pay which is
currently around about seven percent for
mortgages costing uh those with who have
to redo their mortgages about three
thousand pounds extra a year and the
measly 2.3 percent for those that have
got savings so with inflation at around
10 your savings actually reduce in real
value over the year and the banks take
the difference they've been very slow to
pass on the interest rate Rises to those
who were lucky enough to have a little
bit of money in the bank and that
particularly affects people who are
retired and and older and only have
their savings to live on yeah we're
looking at worldwide profits for some of
the banks HSBC are miles ahead of the
others but all of them are making huge
amounts of money do you think they are
are behaving in an unreasonable and
unethical way
well um they've got to prove I think in
their meeting with the financial conduct
Authority today that they're not doing
that the financial conduct Authority are
introducing a thing at the end of this
month called the consumer Duty which is
a general duty for all Financial
Services to treat consumers fairly and
the FDA have to judge what fair is I
think these unwarranted huge extra
profits on Rising interest rates is a
case in point that needs very very close
looking at indeed are you worried about
regulatory overreach not at the moment
you have to look to see how the FCA
behaved but I think the banks uh if you
if you look ahead again at the end of
the month there'll be second quarter
profits recorded just as Parliament
Rises unfortunately and I think you'll
see some pretty colossal profits being
made by the Banks then they've got to
explain whether they're treating
consumers fairly at the moment and think
they are so what you want to see happen
do you want it to mirror the mortgage
interest rate Rises with the savings
interest rate Rises I think there has to
be a much smaller gap between the two
and I'd like to see them passing on
those benefits much faster than they are
doing we know there are a plethora of
different uh
accounts offered and you usually have to
spend your entire working life switching
from the one to the other and it only
lasts six months or a year and then you
have to do it constantly they should
make it much easier for people to
especially loyal customers to maximize
the money that they get for savings it's
never going to be as big as those that
have to borrow pay for obvious reasons
but at the same time the Gap is
ridiculous and unsustainable at the
moment ridiculous unsustainable so just
to clarify you would like to see the
increase not quite the same but more you
know mirroring it more than it does at
the moment smaller Gap yeah and at the
same time as the they must do it faster
I think it's the same with petrol prices
you see it across the economy at a time
when prices are changing rapidly these
hidden extra increases can actually be
be hidden and consumers blame other
things not not the providers themselves
and what then happens is inflation stays
higher well inflation in the UK economy
is actually now a Lagarde in the whole
G7 we've got the highest rates of
inflation and it's sticky it's not
coming down some of the results of this
profiteering in the economy of which
banks are one example is also affecting
the uh rate at which inflation comes
down and making the cost of living
crisis uh worse and making it last
longer
should happen if they don't if they
decide you know what you're whistling in
the wind we're not going to do what
you're asking us to do well governments
can do a range of things I'm not sure
this one will they're having them in for
a nice little cozy chat so that's a good
start but if they refuse to cooperate
then I think the FDA should get much
tougher with them and if if that doesn't
work then the chancellor should have
something to say I'm sure a labor
Chancellor would okay say what
well there's all such you can do with
excess profits uh and there's all sorts
you can talk about windfall I am yes I
am if it's proved that there's a problem
if you if you look at excess profit
making throughout the economy in this
period uh you've got to think about
stuff like that if people don't if if
the suppliers don't listen and they
carry on thinking we can just make our
own profits and there'll be no
consequences except our executive pay
will be higher and is your view mirrored
by the treasury select committee or the
members well there's a range of views on
the treasury select committee but I can
say because it's a conservative majority
on that committee but I can say that all
the members of the treasury select
committee are very worried about this
Gap that's why we wrote the letter uh to
the banks and that's why we wrote to the
financial conduct Authority asking them
to look at it and we're very pleased as
a committee that they are okay it's good
to talk to you thanks for taking the
time to join us down Angela thank you
thank you